[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we're never hey sorry bad part
hey everyone and welcome to another day
of game sports play for all event we're
combining all the big huge gaming
announcements yes we're very excited
about the PS 5 reveal tomorrow but today
we're raising some money for charity and
we have some very special guests joining
us so we are going to be playing apex
legends with some of the cast members of
apex legends so joining us today
we've got Mirage Roger Craig Smith hello
how are you and we have Justine Huxley
yeah hi so in order to play so Roger
you're gonna be playing with the best
name tag in the world it is my favorite
I'm gonna be monitoring Chad monitoring
donations but we have ringers okay so
we're gonna be hopefully carried to some
wins we're gonna get we're gonna be
champions of the arena
we've got Jordan riding oh and Max
Blumenthal heyo
so if you if you've basically seen any
apex content on GameSpot these two are
the ones to thank for making it look so
good but we are here to raise money for
two great causes links on screen right
now black lives matter and Direct Relief
so we are supporting obviously black
lives matter as well as frontline health
care workers who are battling the covert
19 pandemic so please donate I will read
out your name if you have questions for
Roger Oh Justine put them in the chat
please and we will read them out um but
let's get going guys
where's Canyon so we are gonna be doing
some rank today we're gonna be pulling
or garage bronze so we're gonna be
putting them to silver hopefully thanks
though
yeah this is this is gonna be a we made
a new account so we can play with you
and get some got some Bart that's smart
yeah
okay well this is funny because someone
actually in the chat was like who's
gonna be playing leave that to me you
mean rank because I'm a rank doesn't
like really smelly like that's rank
right cuz I'm it's not like a very
British phrase I've never heard it here
right really you've never heard that
that's rank no isn't I I hear it in the
UK a lot but I always figured in those
words that never really liked here too
it's just not as a comment if you like
and no one you would've met you said
what I stacked it stacked it I fell over
are you dropping spice shop in gonna
make it yeah we can make it uh that's
like semi spicy but yeah well just get
warmed up yep uh get a couple games and
this isn't is that a British turn I see
is that something are we we're dropping
spicy I think it originally it's very I
think Spice Girls kind of a thing yeah
super culture Kurt that's why I knew
about rank guys come on boy this is
gonna be yeah so when was the last time
you played apex how about this weather
and it's amazing warm in Southern
California yeah so just so I can know
like who's whose screen is being like
streamed at this point like in terms of
like what the what the folks who are
tuning in and watching this are going to
see no it's gonna be the gap right here
that you're looking at okay good good
okay all I'm gonna do is follow you
until someone kills me I think that's no
no we're gonna get some wins here when
you get some
okay question from chat not normal but
magical says Justine can you say the
wholesome Watson what's in line I did it
I asked about how you guys can't have
add in extra content and how you're
managing to work from home because
obviously everyone is working from home
it's quite nice to be able to see it
like the inside of everyone's houses how
have you managed to sort of adapt your
your work basically no problem
but luckily right when the lockdown
happened I pulled and got soundproofing
and a better mic and better technology
in general my computer my macbook was
he's seven eight years old it sounded
like it was doing some heavy breathing
anytime I opened it so that was not
recording so I got a new computer and I
mean my very tiny closet after recording
and we just had our first report session
from apex the three weeks ago and it
went pretty well um
they seemed key with it and we just
zoomed and you'll hear it I was gonna I
was behind you just like record stuff by
yourself and send it off or do you have
that person in your ear kind of asking
you a bunch of babies yeah the editors
were on voice director was on some tech
people some sound people nice Roger what
about you you're playing - I know and I
was just realizing like this is such a
bad idea like this whole stream is just
gonna be like it's just gonna be a
visual of me kind of going and literally
also done
I'm like I'm completely by myself okay I
don't know where my teammates are gone
I've got to go find them
just follow the ping yeah there you go
and and by ping you mean all the yellow
dye
okay I'll go follow that work from home
it has been something like so for me
working from home I've been fortunate
through necessity as early as like
2006-2007 in there to set up a home
studio studio basically treating a room
in the house to be available for
broadcast quality audio for retail
clients where it was becoming sort of
problematic and it was sort of
advantageous for me to to do that from
home so I've been set up for a long time
to be able to do that sort of thing so
it it was nice to not necessarily be
scrambling by the way speaking of
scrambling I think I'm running around
the Coliseum to try to get to you guys
really got away
okay you can meet us over on this side
here
I'll see you guys in an hour and a half
I could be there in no time
thank goodness you're not well no it's
only because I've literally been off the
map and not with my squad mates so I
like to take pride in living the longest
because I basically hide under a flight
of stairs and just cry The Crying straw
I know it I know yeah it's just you know
a little puddle of my own tears we're
calling it tears all right yeah I'm
already nervous why does the survey
there's no we start at zero yeah it's so
encouraging what's the good news is you
can't get any worse you can I'm sure
there's a way that I would be the way to
find how to get worse
Oh question from chat um where is it
mark Abraham's
how much do you ad-lib when you're
recording voice lines 5x I know you
allowed to ad-lib Watson Roger
probably ad-libs a lot more than I do
I barely ad-lib Beatles punches in
French and I am not fluent in French
definitely helped me out with that I did
take French in high school but it's been
a while so that's one of the things I'm
doing during 14x plans taking French
again because this has really inspired
me to get better at my French this
character but do that much ad-libbing
there's so many electrical puns with
Watson shuffle I just love them so much
the writers are so good that do much at
all but I know Roger does a ton in there
that's and that's kudos to the entire
respond team for even just like allowing
that sort of like development of the
character character to happen cuz it
wasn't it wasn't anything like when I
booked the gig it wasn't as if I was
going in going oh man I'm just gonna
come up with so many funny little quips
and one-liners kind of thing but we in
working together with the writing staff
present that kind of thing we started to
kind of work around the when he kind of
flubs his own lines cuz he's you know
covering for something or thinking too
quick and you know going faster than his
his tongue can kind of keep up that was
just something that started to happen as
a result of us getting in the booth and
and kind of messing around with finding
the character was a lot of the little
things that happen at the end of a line
are just me kind of in that moment
trying to just do something a little
self-deprecating or you know he comes
off with a very arrogant kind of like
you know upfront sort of a line and then
he finishes it with something a little
bit like you know I don't really have
that much confidence been a lot of fun
it's a really fun character to get to go
in and do just because I know I'm gonna
we're gonna all find some stuff that
that when all of us in the room are
cracking up we're like okay that's
that's keeper yeah it works really well
we're getting a few questions in the
chat
film Phoenix sorry if I mispronounced
that username uh what are your favorite
voice I'm I'm Roger what are yours
ladies first the anything is ecstatic my
favorites you so light and Direction
just is there a motorcycle playing with
them no that's just my laptop sorry I
tried moving my mic
literally as you said that a lot more it
kicked off outside a meme it's quite
sound now it's all good put a couple of
donations thank you very much
links are on screen bit ly BLM to donate
to black lives matter or Bly /gs - PO
vid to donate - Direct Relief helping
frontline health care workers for Direct
Relief Shiva Matthew sends $20 and
Matthews Shi ba
yes yes he's a wonderful human being
she's a a very nice supporter of
all of this so thank you Siva that's
very nice of you
he's an educator and she's a hard worker
and and I'm about to die it's okay for
black wives laughter Dexter Brooks $25
thank you
and yeah links on screen or viewing
shout outs if you have questions for
Justine or Roger let us know put them in
the chat we'll read them out some reason
I'm not seeing the chat on the twitch
twitch interesting um Eric
voice in the sky can you text me I gotta
get out of here oh do you have it maybe
everyone's just in YouTube chat cuz
that's the one that we've been pushing
maybe yeah yeah question I have either
of you been recognized while talking on
the phone for example ordering a pizza
or porkchops porch is there a way pork
chops delivered I was unaware of this
look if then it's the new normal you can
get cocktails to go now that's true I do
pork chops
next on men just take that
what a change my agent what's that but
maybe sounds a lot like I don't you know
it's like I was just gonna say I think I
need to change my gamertag to awaiting
recovery even more appropriate gamertag
for me I have never been I have one
person many many years ago recognized me
and it was the weirdest thing for Batman
which kind of was a trip because I don't
think I sound anything like Batman when
I'm just on a customer service call
nobody I'm gonna have to find out if
there's porkchop delivery in my area and
just keep watering porkchops until
somebody goes do you do you play video
games that kind of I do characters that
are little kids or people with accents
about it now and yeah so one of my
characters really sound like me I don't
think no but I guess maybe you dislike
the tone like the tone or the tinge of
it yeah you can kind of hear it
but I was gonna say that so my mom is
obsessed with say yes to the dress is it
is it still airing with my voice on
there like are they still are they still
airing that show I don't think it has a
narrator yeah they got because they got
rid of years ago yeah years ago I
haven't done it for years you can still
hear you on the we can still hear you on
the reruns they play the reruns all time
yeah in the UK there's pretty much a
channel dedicated to it and my mom
watches it all the time and I remember
going back I think is what a year or so
and she was just watching it in the
living room and I went in I was like
wait a minute I know I know that voice
yeah that one gig that was a really neat
that was a really neat gig that was also
kind of indicative of like a change in
the industry for the most part when they
really did start to kind of shift from a
lot of narration a lot of promos these
days don't even have voice actors on
them it's kind of like where things have
kind of shifted we you know there was a
time when narrating you know cable shows
was was my bread and butter between the
the crasher shows on DIY and then that
show we had at one point I think we had
four different sort of spin-off series
oh oh yes the stretch we had yes Atlanta
I think we did a couple different
versions of it you know sort of
throughout the history of the show but
it was a fight that was a fun thing to
be a part of it my favorite thing I had
a fan convention to sit hurt and always
finish with that one like getting heavy
the honor of the meeting up like a whole
bunch of videogame characters but then
also in the period break and of course
narrator for say yes to the dress a
second
come on a point stone look we'll get you
all that to sober pretty soon that's
ready to go guys because Gold's not
achievable first place what are we doing
here yeah we can we can make it all
right it's gotta believe yeah cuz that
got us to I like zero damage was dealt
to me that's what that status for dope
to me nobody hurt me that's how good I
am at this good stealth game yeah there
you go um yeah category of F's given and
zero respawn given zero FS given zero um
question from Daniel Moreno in the chat
would you like for your characters to
evolve over time or do you prefer to
explore different parts of their
personalities I think is there
originally written
you go first on that one you know I mean
it's an interesting thing I'm like I
mean that's really not up to me I guess
I mean I I don't know I'm happy just to
be a part of it so I mean if the idea
that the character just kind of remains
where he's at
I of course be completely fine with it
but if there is the chance to evolve I
mean he's an interesting one to have
that kind of a relationship with that I
I wonder how that would work for a
character like Mirage because I think we
kind of like him sort of simple and
maybe you know it's like I'm sure I'm
sure there's some darkness there we know
we've got some some mommy issues so but
it's but of course I mean like it's an
actor of course I want I want a chance
to sink yo are you always wanting a
chance to kind of sink your teeth into
something so I I would of course welcome
pants for the character to evolve more
but but I wonder what they've got in
store we we rarely find out until we
show up for the gig what we're doing I
mean that's and that's by design
question from the chat just so you kind
of let them know so they're asking who's
playing so the picture that you can see
is our very own max who is the
motorcycle I didn't realize that that's
what his most that's what the motorcycle
was people referring today but also my
laptop loud as hell who's playing with
Jordan and Roger Justine and I are here
for moral support
monitoring the chat questions send them
over and we will answer well they will
answer I will put them to Roger and Jean
we have another donation 25 dollars from
Richie to direct relief thanks to
Justine and Roger for joining GameSpot
for some good causes
Roger is one of my favs in the biz from
Sonic to selling dodge Rams I love it
thank you thank you for that donation
thank you very much thank you
our Richie or another Richie just uh
Richie
you know sunny
my Kelantan never says how far out do
you guys record so say that Roger are we
allowed to say that well I'm in a
generic sense maybe like so how far out
are we recording for like say another
season or anything involving the game
mm-hmm that's just a production thing
that I think I mean that that's that's
completely up to every independent
production that we've ever worked on I
mean it's like sometimes they could do
stuff years in advance sometimes they
could do stuff weeks in advance of
having to launch something or release
something or polishing something up I
mean it really just depends but and
there's no I mean I don't I don't think
we're you know type I don't think we're
divulging anything to top secret if
that's just a production thing I mean
like I've done cartoons where I thought
oh there's no way this is going to be
you know out anytime soon and then
literally like nine months later they're
they're releasing it you just realize
man there's it just depends on its
production timelines and things like
that it varies [ __ ] sorry what we can
say talk to some of the writers about
this and sometimes they do want to put
something in for a season and they can't
because the localization takes so long I
think the localization other languages
takes at least three months scope I know
that yeah with the quests know that you
know a lot of people were disappointed
that our voices weren't sick those lines
of the quest but takes so long to get
everything approved and to get all of
the other languages so we in the future
we'll do some quests you never know I'm
hoping at some point because I love
those quests I love those storylines so
sad when Watson got injured yeah
boiler alert
[Laughter]
let's years in internet time treacherous
question for Roger who would you like to
see as one of mirages brothers if he
ever comes to Apex Troy Baker or Nolan
North yeah we had we had Troy on
yesterday and he did say to say hello he
misses you you also asked to connote he
said that he said that's what a man does
yes he says he really enjoys like goof
from my short-lived manly grooming
podcast that I did on Instagram there
yeah yeah that's what a mad man I sang
this is what a man does I live alone so
I'm in a house by myself doing just that
now yeah I miss joy - it's like we
haven't seen each other in a long time
and the answer of course to either one
of those individuals being a part of
this game is yes I mean take your pick I
I recently did an animation session with
with Nolan from home and and it was just
fun kind of being back in the boots per
se with with that guy and cracking each
other up and a lots of them so yes I
would welcome either one of them that
would be a blast
why not blow it Rob do you find yourself
talking to yourself often
yeah I guarantee you when I was when I
was delivering pizzas I was still
talking to myself teen or just voice
actor I was organically that the voice
came out of me to give a voice to one of
the bubbles and it's just like where did
this come from
I get the job done no it sounds about
right that would be me I'm just jumping
with the goose are here there we go yeah
you're doing the boogie to steppin
there we go oh yeah
see that I'm really good at teabag yes
there you go is that's that's I think I
hit somebody got you yeah either a way
deeper or reviving that's gonna be the
new gamertag my favorite thing so I
didn't I say it's yours from the person
you killed okay cuz I playing
PlayStation and I didn't realize for the
longest time but if you press down on
the touchpad it brings up the keyboard
so because I'm usually dead most of the
time I just wrote helped me I'm sorry
and then it reads it out in a robotic
voice I love it and so that's what
that's what the experience is playing
apex with me just me apologize I'm the
guy who goes like hey I got a Mozambique
that's good right oh yeah yeah good okay
I'm gonna throw it at somebody so I
actually do some damage it's got more
internet power than you think
it's mean potential was pretty high Oh
Alex Corrales asks Roger do you get
along with crypto cuz there's some beef
in the game a little bit of beef you
know I think he's got a thing where he
thinks I'm old and really appreciate
that don't really appreciate judgment in
his tone you know
I guess no what's that Mirage I don't
even know I mean really
beauty is timeless when you think about
it you know it's funny I don't think I
even know that I
I don't remember let me let me look it
up like mentally or physically age the
the headline and this is a fix legends
law now includes mirages it is okay be
okay yeah you say that okay clearly
you've never played with me before soon
from the chat can you both do your best
Mozambique here it's I mean they they
tended like in post-processing they kind
of lower my pitch and then they lower it
and make him sound sexier I guess yeah
nothing at that art yeah wait people
each other asking for the dating profile
I want to end it yeah yeah yeah calm oh
wow it really is soulless dating okay
name so I just took like a normally like
oh oh wait a minute
seeking seeking women age 25 to I don't
know 25 to alive real
it's quite it's quite in-depth they stay
profile I want to see that I think I do
think I remember seeing this I'm
wondering if we even I don't know that
we've recorded anything for it though I
can't remember maybe on the Mirage
voyage the my doing these great party
awesome really hope you recorded that
beside for my side job is actually my
passion and I'm considered legendary
when it comes to my passion when I'm not
doing that I'm murdering pork chops and
flirting and some delicious drinks I
don't actually murder pork chops that's
just weird
unless you're into that kind of thing
like you're in alright I think I might
have gotten seven points for damage
dealt like it's better it's better than
nothing yeah yeah yeah every every
little helps literally I don't I don't
know that either of my colleagues would
say that right now he actually has to do
a little bit of something for it to help
so I mean actually in that last game you
saved my life during like one of the
skirmishes you came by here so by
drawing the fire of the person trying to
kill you yeah there you go
whether it be a clone or your your buddy
question for Justine from fahad sack
saying
Justine can you share your experience on
what it was like working with JB Blanc
who plays caustic since they have that
surrogate father-daughter relationship
in apex and most video games we don't
record together unfortunately I wish we
recorded together because it would be so
much button but can you record all of
our lines by ourselves and the only time
I get to see you guys in the recording
studio is saying hello or goodbye you
know when they come in and wouldn't I go
out so we I have never even seen him in
a recording studio but just at parties
and you know get together
I love the relationship between caustic
and Watson I love their father-daughter
relationship I think it's so cool that
if we're exploring that um and I think
she's the only one that that really was
him up and makes him a little less lien
and gassy how's the match going it's
going well yeah I think I got seven
points for hitting someone with a bullet
either that I might have actually
tickled them to be honest so maybe I got
seven points for tickling well at the
rate we're going I think you'll make
silver guys drink you like it I mean
yeah very well
Isabella Lopez hello just um Roger what
are you what's your favorite thing about
your character's personality Justin oh I
love bright
how awesome she is I love the triple
puns obviously they're the best I love I
love that she is a little bit devious
with her with her Ultimates and
electrical spark she's great and I love
the cheese French because it makes me
your subject for my for my central a
state Rocha uh you know it's going to
have it I've had
I've had people asked like of all the
characters that I've you know voiced
Who am I most like sorry I like my right
brain left brain right now is is no I am
XK modem here kind of going I'm just
trying to stay alive and not harm my
teammates I've had people ask you know
what what character might you be like
the most and honestly the the little
self-deprecating elements of Mirage are
very much me that that's what I like
about poisonous character and there we
go
Oh waiting let me see I got you you got
me
well in a second oh no
okay you what I love about Mirage is
that that sort of front of like oh well
all right guys well why did you rank my
program feed is like a little pixelated
so I can't see the finer details 31 31
31 points I mean it's mostly keep
getting this high then we should be able
to make it oh yeah all right what I love
about love about Mirage is just those
little self-deprecating element because
I think that's a very that's what makes
him not just the the sort of goofball
that he the fact that you know that he's
kind of you know going out maybe I'm not
so great you know at the tail end of
things or hearing that little bit of
self-doubt I love that hello because I
think that's that's true of most human
beings we all have our little
insecurities and things like that and if
we posture to be all tough and whatnot
it's like you're you're one horrible
match away from being shown you're not
you're not you're not a little element
to add to his to his life that's that's
my favorite thing about Mirage is that
the bravado followed by the maybe I'm
not so bravado asked a question for my
very own Timon who's saying which video
game franchise do you most want to do a
voice in Roger you go first of that I
mean I vote it's like that's always an
interesting question I mean really and
truly so much of what we do is like it's
the gig and so I mean that the Pat
answer for me is always the next one
yeah and and so and the idea to like
I've been so fortunate and even just to
like even just to be this age and get to
go like well in my career and say stuff
like that feels like so weird because we
love doing the job so the idea that that
there's something else ahead is like
it's a luxury that I don't think you
want to sit
believe too much in so for me it's the
next one and then I think about this
medium over the on camera world really
is that between animation and video
games it I mean they were limited by our
imagination and that's it and there are
so many creative people creating so many
incredible projects that every time I
start to wonder man I wonder if we've
just plateaued about all the things that
we can do or it's like no there's a new
way to tell a story there's a new way to
visually do this now we've got VR kind
of completely changing the way we do
things so it's I mean there's you know
the idea that I would pick and choose a
particular franchise to be a part of
when I've already been so fortunate to
be a part of I mean just how big a pecs
is it's just insane so I don't know I
whichever one would have me I'd be more
than happy to be a part of so I've got
two very nice comments for Justine
so Adrian yo-yo says salut can you tell
Justine that I'm French and that her
French accent is great no joke well I
had a very very strict teacher from
Alsace and if our accents weren't to her
liking we would get in big trouble so
that helped I think a lot and the other
one is Elodie says I just want to say to
justine that you're such a huge
inspiration for me and I have a massive
fan of yours and your work okay leave
the game as soon as we're done like that
and just go back to the lobby
does that help you guys out and getting
here okay cool thank you yeah I kind of
figured I was I was like I'm sandbagging
yet again you're doing great we've got a
couple more donations so links are on
the screen right now we are raising
money for black lives matter as well as
Kovan 19 going to direct relief there so
links are bitter ly /gs - BL and the
black lives matter bit ly flash GS -
Kovach Direct Relief $20 from a very own
Erte for cove aedra leaf shoutouts to
two of the many wonderful voice actors
slash characters in an awesome game
thanks for coming on today and hanging
out with us let's get to
fooling and making Papa proud thank you
I was wait that was working every single
possible connection and $20 to black
lives matter from Katie Cooper thank you
very much thank you Katie
thank you Chad says Brandon honda says
tomorrow Hussein who works with us needs
to do some voice work for the new blood
borne if they ever make another one so
what advice would you give to people if
they wanted to start out and voice work
Justine
so I'm one of our friends Dee Bradley
Baker who's well voice actor who just
does the most sand creature voices he
has a wonderful website called I want to
be a voice actor calm and it is AIDS II
many great tips tricks about you
starting out being a voice actor to the
working voice actor to the pro voice
actor sometimes if I have a callback
I'll go back and look at that website
and just a myself a certain bullet
points that I want to remember when
going in
it goes from setting up your home studio
to make sure you don't wear a Mickey
Mouse shirt when you're going into a
nickel an audition which is smart so I
really recommend anyone about it
the bath website but also take acting
classes so many voiceover classes
Marilyn Wissner who's casting director
and she does flexes on zoom right now
because of the lockdown a fantastic
resource her company is called voices
voice casting and there's there's so
many um whisper coaches my one of my
voiceover coaches Lorri Allen who is on
SpongeBob and was on Family Guy's she
does Skype and zoom coaching online
great coach and you know this is
exacting is all about Joe nation and B
do create a character with your voice
yeah wait what happened there yeah yeah
pretend nothing happened
stupi 2020s is not gonna get me anywhere
one of you guys was just like trolling
me by like shooting at my feet and and
so I like foolish it was like oh wait
you guys are trying to get my cuz I mean
it was just like drop in all of a sudden
bullets at my feet and I turned around
to see who it is and it's I got a nice
finishing move right away about 15
seconds of but again zero damage dealt
it be like that actually I have a
question during this whole croon of a
virus pandemic how is that affected you
guys has work there you go first oh well
obviously you've got a lot of different
companies in a lot of different ways
that have been affected by the shutdown
very very very fortunate that on this
side of the industry I mean in the on
camera world it's done and with
voiceover work and animation video games
we've managed to get some sessions still
go
and while it's nowhere near what it was
prior to the to the lock downs I'm
thrilled at the chance to be able to
work because I know way too many
colleagues who are who work in different
sort of facets of the on camera world
that are just they're just out of work
and there's and there's no option and so
for us to have been able to find ways to
do things I had a session this morning
animation session from home and it's
like to be able to do that and then to
go do stuff like this and not traffic
and all that it's a memory position so
the work has slowed for sure but very
grateful and very fortunate to be able
to still have opportunities to to
salvage some work here and there Ellie I
think all the most of the promo jobs
were from home way like my promo job
that I have always been from home so
I've been lucky about that but animation
and the video games and some commercials
were from home but most done have been
in actual studios so um it's definitely
different I seeing people in person I
miss able to a a real studio but um but
under said we're so lucky because so
many people are not working when you'll
like getting attached to a project like
do you have any idea what its gonna be
or do you just kind of get a call for
hey we need voice for this character
here is some vague things about them to
help find that voice but you don't do
you know what project it's gonna be
attached to I think it totally depends
on the project um the game I had no idea
what it was going up the code names for
free you know secretive and and know
what I auditioned that it was going to
be apex legends I also auditioned and
started recording before the game came
out even though my character didn't come
out until July I heard a recording a few
months before the game came out so I
really had no
I didn't really know much about my
character besides the fact that she was
French and that she was a scientist um
loved electricity and that she liked
some puns I think I did two puns in the
audition and a really quick audition
from home and I didn't think anything
because I try and do is when I audition
I try and forget it like the day after
because I don't want to think about all
the things that I um when sometimes when
my agent calls or emails and says I
booked a job you can just eat am I just
chatting in the new three going I'm just
trying to not screw up getting some
questions about Ezio and Mirage
I'll save those who when you in between
rounds whoa Jeff okay sure remember what
the question was that I wanted to say -
this was actually kind of an issue that
that the Union was trying to address
I came to sort of intellectual property
and and afters not being aware of games
that they were going in on and I had to
call my agent before to say did you look
at the audition copy that you just sent
to me because the subject matter was so
highly questionable and and there does
come a point where you might want to sit
there and think do I want to be a part
of this or not and I'm all for you know
freedom in all forms of expression but
if there's also a
something to be said for whether or not
you're comfortable being a participant
and and I've I've done so many little
like kids series and things like that
that I have to talk to my agent every
now and then going look I'm gonna go
from being you know on an Amazon you
know preschool series to screaming the F
word over and over and over again on
this game and I don't know that we want
to do that right now maybe we shouldn't
maybe we shouldn't be a part of this or
there there's been stuff where I'm like
like this the visual description what
was happening and my agent hadn't really
like looked into it and all of a sudden
he's cracking up calling me going yeah I
know we're gonna submit on this and so
actors sometimes know because it results
in some pretty awkward scenarios where
you want the gig and you want to show up
and you want to work and then you get
there and it might be something that you
morally object to and and that's up to
the individual to be able to make that
decision and you can't do that if you
don't tell what you're going in on so
they're trying to find a way of not
giving up their industry secrets through
the casting process but also you know
benefiting accurate talking about what
it is they're about to be a part of
right sorry no I was what's tonight he's
already down to different squads I think
so I think you got pin side a little bit
seventy-four damaged l that's twice much
and the only other game where damage has
been dealt by this guy right here
getting better already
just needed some hands-on teaching from
these two basically you know I'm twice
as good as I've ever been
that's a hundred percent increase more
than a hundred percent increase in math
stuff yeah uh-oh this is a good question
this is from Jamie French
do you enjoy listening to your own voice
after you do a project can you listen to
yourself back when I first played apex
it was a TA play and I hadn't heard any
of the play of Watson yet it was really
exciting because it was this new
character coming out and that was very
exciting for me but sometimes it's hard
because you're like oh gosh done this
instead or what why they choose that
take I did like 50 other takes it could
have chosen another thing but um but
sometimes it's it's fun you know
especially on a cartoon like if I'm
watching a cartoon with my friends kids
they you know start freaking out because
you know Little Red Riding Hood and and
they're like oh you know it's it's
really adorable Oh it depending it by
myself I can wise it like crazy but if
it's my mom or with a friend or
especially kids love it it's it's much
more fun same goes I mean it's it's so
funny like one of the neat things about
this aspect of the business is that it's
such a huge collaborative process that I
always try to at least get a copy of the
game and start playing through it
because we're so limited in what we get
to experience
oh I'm jumpmaster sorry guys I'm sure we
probably already passed over we're a
nice hot and spicy jump should have been
no I think it's up to the individual to
you know whether or not they're
comfortable with it but because I don't
get to see what we're a part of because
it's almost always theater of the mind
at the time we're doing these reporting
sessions I really enjoy watching an
animated series when it comes out I
enjoy watching you know or or playing
through a game that that I you know
provided a voice for only because I've
made the little comet it's a it's like a
job is birthing out this vote
baby and then I hand it over to a group
of people who sort of determine whether
or not that baby is gonna be cute or
ugly or you know have a weird you know
arm growing out of its forehead or
something very straight babies and so
it's it's neat to see what the entire
creative team developed and sort of
executed and and watching the be sort of
like collective creative vision come to
fruition is a neat thing and of course
just like Justine I every line that I
hear that I've ever delivered I I almost
always go I could have polished that up
or done a better job or done something
differently or you know it's but that's
the that's the the nature of it being a
collaborative environment where it's a
lot of people are gonna you know get a
say as to how this this thing sort of
comes out in the end and that that to me
is the fun part of kind of going oh man
look at that I didn't know that that's
what my character even looked like you
know which has happened many times oh
this is this is questions come up a
couple times
Justine what do you think about Watson
being one of the top legends and
professional apex I just think that's
the coolest thing because I'm such a bad
apex player that is amazing that the
character that I voice is one of the top
last time we went the studio as a as a
big voice cast played as Watson and had
about seven devs behind me cooking me
because I'm so terrible and I beat I
beat the head of respond I beat it which
was extremely exciting but I mean I
think it was a big win exciting
it was a oven in the chat so it's
Justine can you tell us one of your
jokes I'm sorry to put you on the spot
but they've been they've been requesting
this for quite a while I have available
two player and what is coming up and I
don't want to say anything that yes
that's a good point just a good
knock-knock joke then she's great um
great I like I like um I'm currently at
the top of my game
spot-on thing she has a lot of
cringe-worthy dad jokes she fights
undelete hurts a bumper sticker from
where it was like it was it like it was
I think there's an electricians vehicle
and it was like you know it's like you
know plumbers do it till it this or you
know musicians too like this and it was
like electricians do it till it hurts
sorry David very good I was like okay I
get an HD
that's brilliant uh Danny on PC said
Watson forgetting her joke just shocking
oh man no gotta go I sound like a dude
says do you have a favorite skin or
looks for your characters and question
for me if that skin doesn't exist
already what would you like to see your
character dressed up as thinking like
hot dog hot dog outfit
[Laughter]
[Music]
just a giant pork chop lying around
yeah I'm John pork chop or either that
like I don't know bottle of hair spray
for Mirage maybe just like a night
bottle of hairspray or conditioner or
something or a giant mirror he'd love it
as a giant hand mirror that'd be him
good questions ugly dude I love the the
Watson Simon skin I thought that was so
cool I love to pink hair magenta hair oh
but I am pushing for the electric eel
costume kind of electric eel thing like
for Halloween - as our characters that
would be fun this could be in like five
Halloween's from now so for every
playing like a localized version because
I see Raviv a Raviv a Raviv a for both
of my squad mate there you go changer we
you got this that's Spanish we've got
this it's been doing great exactly it's
like just keep going I gray fox asked a
wedgie wedgie place wedgie place it's
time we placed asks have Roger and
Justine work together on another project
in the past or is Apex the first one the
first yeah yeah is the first time we
worked together that was the question
was yeah yeah no I believe so yeah I
think the first time that I met Justine
was at that when we got a little sort of
tour of the the respawn the respawn
headquarters
Oh case I'm droid are you up for doing
cosplay
of your characters well any cat or any
character if you could cause play any
character who would it be
um it would love to but bomb it with the
cosplay for Watson if someone wanted to
make me because never bots and I would
be happy to wear it um I'm not a sewer
and probably not I love Halloween I love
making things for Halloween
like homemade costumes like gluing
things and I've been a bunch of grapes
in it and salad and I was this year I
was a woman from Blue Man Group so I do
make a lot of my own costumes but feel
like costume I would not say no I had an
option like an opportunity years and
years and years ago when PlayStation was
doing a really cool like like pro gamer
kind of commercial where they were
taking all of these characters it was
called like to Michael or for Michael or
something like that and it was it was in
celebration of gamers and and they got
like I mean like they had Solid Snake
they had Nathan Drake they I'm like at
all these iconic sort of gaming
characters and they wanted Ezio to be in
this commercial and they contacted my
agency and they were like we want to fly
him out to Prague to do this
live-action commercialize that's he I'm
cracking up going there is not enough
bronzer in the world that make me look
like this Italians you know lover boy
assassin guy I'm like you do know that
I'm 5 foot 5 right like this is and they
literally also brought me in on like the
casting of that it was the funniest
thing they had me they wanted me to like
show up to a casting and and I did this
on a day when they were also casting for
Lara Croft
in the in the commercial
and so here I am I walk in and my like
you know ball cap and cargo shorts you
know to this like on-camera casting
facility which is like basically my
nightmare and the the waiting room is
full of you know beautiful women dressed
as Lara Croft it's like it I'm do was to
literally go in and start like mock
flirting with these other characters
Ezio and yet the girl that they selected
to do this with I'm like looking up at
her like this like you know how are you
she's like three feet taller than I and
so I always laugh when it comes to like
cosplaying my own character just go
there I do a good enough job just in
interviews like this of ruining the
characters that I've part of so you
don't want to see it that's not so so
far what we're in Cuzco and I do really
well is just just tea bagging general
ground here and there that's yes you
know I can see the gameplay there that's
good do you ever wonder like if if video
games a more realistic what gaming
characters thighs would actually be like
with all the tea bagging and the
squatting they'll be very powerful yeah
a lot of like like defensive linemen in
the NFL sized tree trunk thighs for sure
we got a couple more donations links are
on the screen and in the description if
you want to click and donate in raising
money for black lives matter as well as
a direct relief raising money for
frontline healthcare workers battling
over 19 for direct relief we have $25
from chastity Atencio YC drop but thanks
to the stream y'all I love apex and the
voice work in the game is fantastic and
for black lives matter we've got one
from Megan mines $5 and $25 from Ali
Mohammed thank you everyone
yeah thanks so much um oh yes this is a
good question
from Bishop Roger how did the Game
Awards Christmas event
reveal kind of come together and what
was it like to do that and probably one
of the most surreal things I've ever had
an opportunity to be a part of and if
you want to talk about you know when
when life just kind of flashes by when
they teased the concept of what they
were thinking about doing I just
remembered thinking you might go but
live live fully rendered mocap of both
facial movements and body movements and
all that and interacting piped into
another you know building and all that I
just thought man that all the things in
the sort of supply chain that could that
could go wrong that's such an ambitious
thing to consider and then we did a test
like a couple months beforehand and I
went okay all right with some pickups
here and there that kind of thing it was
it was just incredible everything like I
they could have showed an even more
behind the scenes of what of what they
pulled off just because it was so
incredible to see such a large team of
people kind of coming together for this
literally two minutes and 15 seconds of
oh man oh man oh man I hope this goes
well and it was incredible it was it was
a neat thing to see there were a lot of
a lot of hard-working people that said
you know for days on end put in a ton of
effort pulling that off and the fact
that we did pull it off and did it live
and that a lot of folks did not realize
that it was done live that that you were
just across the quad from the theater
and you know in just a tiny little room
and and a bank of computers which a
thank you he's been working on it and
all that it was just it was a neat thing
but I was so petrified that it just you
know we did - about two solid days of it
so we did a lot of like day one was one
scene two days
no it was day it was the day before that
we got on site ran through everything
over and over and over and over again
and then I think we had a tech rehearsal
that day with the theater production
team and then on the day
of we did a bunch of run throughs and
just kind of making sure that everybody
we were we were kind of like like
condensing everything with every hour
that would pass like okay let's do one
more run and now this is going to be
like when we know we're 30 minutes out
it's like because there's so many things
with it with the technical aspect and at
one point somebody of course about I
think maybe 45 minutes before this was
supposed to happen
bumped one of the cameras the little
infrared cameras they say true and it
was like people could not believe that
it happened and it was like so they go
on they reset the whole world all that
like it was all like all those little
things so then we were rehearsing to be
like okay we're 30 minutes out everybody
just stay where you are and it was like
you know let's and then when we're 15
minutes out Roger you stand up and get
ready you know like and it's so the
whole time you like your adrenaline is
just going like haywire and and when you
just think about all the things that
could go wrong the audio feed from the
theater I might not have been able to
hear Keeley's microphone I mean it's
like all the things that could have
happened I could have easily flubbed one
of my lines I could have forgotten
something all that stuff and it didn't
happen and we pulled it off and it was a
there's a very new moment no definitely
memorize and and and memorized and then
had put little bullet points up on the
front of what we call the camera that's
the other weird thing about mocap is
that you know the camera is like
somebody who's just holding something in
front of you there a lens there's no
nothing it's just everything it's sort
of understand how to render the the sort
of reflective dots and turn it into this
digital puppet of sorts and so on the
front of that I had put bullet points of
the things that we were supposed to try
to get to and I never of course even
bothered with it I it's like literally
it's like the eyes were all up in the
back of the head and you just sort of go
into autopilot and try not to think
about what it is that you're doing and
just sort of just you know hope that it
works it was the closest thing I've had
to going back to to the days of like
stand-up comedy when you knew you had
like you know and you're starting out
you got seven minutes to go up and try
to do the best job you can and it felt
like that and
and I don't miss that feeling I don't
miss that feeling but it was such
anything again like there were so many
people that pulled it all off and it was
such a neat thing for EAN respawn and
the mill to work on for that fan base I
mean what a neat thing to do for apex
Legends fans I was just I couldn't
believe that that they had asked me to
be a part of it and that I was entrusted
with being able to pull it off so it was
a really just I such a nice you know
warm fuzzy over that whole thing it was
just such a cool thing to be a part of
Zehra puzzle says yeah hey Raja a great
question she's our apex legends voice
sir I'm seeing something countdown
yeah Mirage Mirage has a little thing
for the he's always like very high the
by the voice I forget what he calls her
but like you know like something it's
something like you know the sexy the
sexy announcer voice or something like
that he's kind of thing now I wasn't in
chat uh said uh no worries that I've
lost it it was a great question
Roger it was it was a foul have you ever
rage punched a boulder yeah no I've rage
quit a videogame but I've never I've
never raged punched a boulder only Chris
Redfield would do something is as crazy
as that I know well leave with the
Capcom and that kind of stuff you just
like what I did but of course I I don't
know why like even today I have no
weapon I'm so fat
yeah daddy OPP is going for please get
you I know
I'm just okay this is yeah yes and we're
eliminated there we go
well I just love the fact that it's like
there's giant tarantulas in the game
throughout and the whole time and that's
the one thing that people remember like
but it was so fake when he starts
punching a boulder at the end like I
don't know guys it's a lot a lot of
suspension of disbelief that's going on
throughout that entire game oh how did
that one go that game couldn't have gone
better
yeah yeah like I said you guys thought
that it's like no you will carry you
along no no I mean you weren't getting
points though writing about seven at a
time so you know pretty good I mean
you'll get extra for being in a group
you'll get extra for to see surviving
really patient trophies thank you pretty
much like Ione I need say this cuz I'm
not playing and so you can't see how bad
that I am good thank you
I am always the one who's just hiding
behind a rock and they're just kind of
waiting until everyone else gets killed
and then go and get killed yeah that's
what I do I take a lot of pride in
survival time as yeah yeah first one in
the last one out but doing nothing in
between those two moments so it's great
yeah exactly
ha as voice acting changed um actually
no there was a great very good question
in the chat when someone was asking
what's the difference between acting in
video games compared to doing TV
animation movies a lot of times in
animation for cartoons
give you your film well not not so much
for film but for TV you'll do a group
record it'll kind of be like a radio
play and it really depends on the show
though cuz there there's been shows that
I've done where you're recording with
one other person or you're recording
with two people or you're recording with
like other people so it really depends
um or sometimes you're just recording by
yourself but a lot of times if you are
recording by yourself you're having the
voice director do the other lines so
it's it's more collaborative I feel like
with or like acting with someone else
for videogames at least for legends and
some other video games I've worked on
it's all you you have to create that
story in your head you're totally on
your own I'm not supposed to answer that
am i you're welcome to two things at
once and that's I have reached my limit
that's all right
folks in the chat and who are watching
from home we are raising money for black
lives matter as well as Direct Relief
the links are on the screen and also in
the description please donate we're
having a really fun time playing epics
legends with Justine Huxley and Roger
Craig Smith we're here for another 45
minutes or so hopefully gonna get a win
that's the that's positive stuff I
believe I believe we might want to have
somebody take over for me if that's the
case I don't know we're gonna make it oh
there's a pred on our trail that's great
there what could possibly go wrong
actually going off the other question
from earlier if there was a cosplay for
Mirage would you wear it to me yeah yeah
but I'll maybe only as a joke I mean I I
cannot I I have a hard enough time
taking myself seriously just as a
regular human being let alone somebody
who would like pull this off and in that
way maybe it's just a lot
like mirages be like yeah I can't do
this I can't pull this off so I think
that would be that's just how it would
be for me it wouldn't I don't know I and
again I mean it's like I mean the hair I
can't do the hair I mean I just
yeah the height the ya know yeah I'm
looking I'm getting I'm literally
sweating thinking about that so um
oh how to pronounce this I hope I don't
butcher this too much and ni ek me what
you interesting have you met are the
apex characters in real life and do you
meet them often doing voice acting okay
I was already friends with Allegra Clark
before bequest in apex we now it is you
know that from the very beginning we
were taking classes together taking
workshops casting director workshops we
neither of us had booked very much so
I've known Allegra for years and I was
so excited what nice book Dave going
into the studio because I was asking
with weather which other voice actors
are in the game and they said Allegra
and then I ran into her at a callback
were we whispered to each other so that
was very exciting for me obviously she's
leaving her friend so sweet and so
wonderful and hilarious and yes we do we
we have a group that just goes on and on
sometimes out for a walk and I'll come
back and there's 68 messages and I'm
like wow
usually like who plays chewbacca it's
like him with his just pictures of
Maui's sunsets and hit and his blowing
hair and Roger
you know seeing something ridiculous and
hilarious and we've done karaoke Rutter
missed it but yeah the next time we we
get to do karaoke in person Rogers got a
joint because that was pretty epic
Darrin DePaul who please rub that was do
know with allegra and it was uh it was
revenant version Oh perfect yeah it was
so scary
I was gonna say when you do karaoke do
you do it as justine as Roger or do you
do it as your characters and what is
your go-to karaoke song oh gosh um I
love I see a little
that's one of my favorites also natural
woman here okay
anything Carol King I love um just do it
as myself just having fun um which
everyone was just doing it as themselves
but Darrin had to do a little cuz why
not Rajjo is very oaky I'm trying to
think like you know like Oh or or would
he be more like abracadabra by Steve
Miller Band you know yeah
bamboozled mm-hmm
very good we've got a few donations I'm
gonna read out thank you everyone for
donating links on the screen and in the
description if you'd like to donate to
black lives matter or directly or bugs
so Zahra donated $25 to both causes
thank you so much
we have watch man who watches the
Watchmen I donated $20 to Direct Relief
now was directed donated $20 a Direct
Relief and way to go annoyingly
tilta fire has cut off the half of you
username it's just this way to go gam
but thank you donated $50 to Direct
Relief thank you so much thank you
um that was a good question Oh so Andrew
Steffensen says love to see this as an
aspiring voice actor question for both
what was the most fun project they've
worked on except for apex legends sure
oh no no you please no no please hagh
away
a Disney jr. show called Golden Bear for
many years where I played Little Red
Riding Hood and the old woman who lives
in a shoe and a bunch of characters like
dancing eggs the friends with Humpty
Dumpty and I just had the best time that
was the first animated show I ever
booked and it's what kept me in LA I was
it was about two years ago I booked it
and was five years old I was thinking
moving back and doing a theater in New
York and when I booked it I was it
realize you know what la you know I
still had an agent but I was really torn
between theater and musical theater and
full-time and so it kept me in LA and
really opened up a lot of over
opportunities for me so I loved that so
much I also got to sing on the show I
love to sings wonderful experience for a
second but nice
the problem is is every time I watch my
ex play I'm always constantly reminded
of that I will never reach these Heights
I mean having a hard time right now
that's terrible you have an anvil for a
teammate you're doing great yeah it's
hard like I know that I can't do it I
can't play and talk at the same time and
so let alone like playing a game like
Apex what you kind of have to be paying
attention and listening other people so
yeah I do have a question from the chat
about playing Batman but will let's hold
that until we are in between yeah yeah
yeah Batman cool come on what's how do I
jump again weird
Hillary you can I can't even I'm
spinning in circles are you guys we're
here there's my Batman how do I get my
cape out again
I feel like I'm doing more harm to
respawn than I am any good but again I
think the game some of the rounds fun is
just the ones where everything goes
wrong
yeah okay it's good were you ever a
cheerleader in life or we never I don't
I'm an emotional cheerleader there you
go we never had them in the UK really
I've never heard of anyone being a
cheerleader in the UK you're not missing
out on it did watch some of that Netflix
show about them and it just looked
terrifying in a lot of work nothing like
wasn't there a documentary on like cheer
camp or something like that that was
just intense yeah yeah and it was it was
very I don't know I think people don't
realize how much work it is because oh I
told Jim mastics and stuff too and
they're just you know awful videos of
people being dropped I don't know oh
yeah oh yeah this long I think is the
best
yeah baby packs of the voice cast Roger
do you think it's Chris or do you think
it's John I think is the best for a baby
packs of the voice cast do you think
Ronnie both really good it seems like oh
yeah I mean I don't know enough Oh too
mad I mean Johnny seems like he's
squatting up a lot and although but
Johnny voices Krypto and I'm not
supposed to be supportive but then Chris
is the talking robot so it's like this
but that's a tough one for for me you
know because I'm always in character I'm
very method as an actor he's he's
blocked cryptos blocked in the in the
apex legends group chat
oh yeah absolutely yeah thank you yeah
the smiling robot thankfully doesn't
have much to say anyway so let's just
we'll keep it at that
no I I honestly don't know I I that'd be
interesting and
Dave and they squatted up org wait no
cuz Johnny's people isn't he I think
they're on different platforms yeah I
think in fact they might even be
considering that I think johnny was
considering getting onto Xbox or
something like that and doing that
tonight when I played with Chris they
just we everybody just laughs at us
because it's like this is the longest
I've ever survived in any one of my
games I think and actually probably
combined the totality of all of my games
combined probably doesn't come close to
how long I've lived in this one match
wait we're gonna be how to win before no
really I don't think I doubt that
seriously cuz man the pressures really
mounting now playing yeah no I don't
think um no I don't think I can't
remember I got one win or not
I could probably look on my profile
right yeah your your achievements will
have one okay maybe on our next little
one side I I'll look into that Jim McGee
says someone talked about Chris is
getting a PC to play with people on PC
and Johnny is about to borrow an Xbox
one oh cool that's perfect there you go
that'll be interesting Justine that'd be
fun too
what we also need to do is like have all
of us that are just just awful all squat
up and go against them and just walk
them troll us like you know how who
keeps shooting at my foot al who keeps
you together like that going on that's
pretty good
Allegra I think kind of Branson most
definitely doesn't yeah yeah no I I
would imagine between those three it's
got to be and they're all very capable
that's what's uh
that's what's funny about me even we
have to come on here and do this
thank you and Mack I'm so sorry
cuz when you said we were playing ranked
I just remember thinking well that can't
sell anything good for you oh no word
will be we'll be doing better in here
because the best be mm it's fine it is
this is all planned o SP mm I mean
that's what we're supposed to say right
that's what yeah what do you think of
that the internet social media artists
ISM fix SB mm I did on Twitter for April
Fool's that I had become the newest apex
Legends dev and I was gonna be this this
senior your level designer and people
bought it like crazy I got so funny
remove SV mm you know this you need to
it was like like No
[Music]
ever met me or if you give me a lot of
Twitter people have it but if you if you
know anything about me you know I'm not
a gamer this game and so it was just so
funny and then it was funny because the
devs weren't friends with like private
message team they were like welcome to
the team we're so excited you know is
that what's going on this is black squad
oh sorry guys yeah hashtag awaiting
recovery oh this might be it this game
crashed it look alive
yeah yeah yeah look at that achievement
unlocked
yeah that's your first win then oh yeah
Roger do you want to keep playing on you
want to like try and get someone random
an old and you know to get someone
random in and let these guys win a game
I dealt 5 damage
oh yeah and gotta kill some how how does
yeah that can help excuse me so would
away cuz I'm I'm so excited I'm choking
up my own spit how do I so I returned to
the lobby and then want me to leave the
party and you'll guess I'll invite you
actually knows how to play video games
it'll just match make them right if you
guys want to keep playing and we can
chat and you're not gonna be in the zone
oh yeah so people to answer questions
and yeah yeah yeah okay let's do that so
let me let me not ready are you all
ready just leave the uh leave the party
yeah that works and then we can just go
two of us that would be okay cool people
in chat saying life damage is still
damage thank you you're all waiting
you're kind it's like what is it there's
an old joke the optimist of the optimist
fell off the the top store or the top
the fell off the roof of a hundred
storey building and at each window bar
on the way down kept calling out to
people below okay so far let's see yes
you dispose while I'm like how do I
leave a party again startlingly yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure I want to leave
that party if they had a vote they'd be
saying yes he wants to leave the party
I'm sorry sticking with these accounts
are moving to her everyone oh I guess we
could go to the main one now
arretez that's the insult to the injury
thank you gentlemen
no it's like physically impossible to
play with you unranked without touching
account so all I heard was it's
physically impossible to play with you
that's that's just that's not what I say
that's fine so while they're getting
sort of budget
question earlier what was it like
playing back we still play Batman in a
number of things what was it like
wearing the cowl following in the
footsteps of Kevin Conroy so I've never
worn the cowl it just ruins the
character for everybody you know and
again if it's like for one I'd be way
too hot at comic-con trying to do that
and then I'd probably have too many
people like picking me up as Batman or
you know patting me on the head is bad
we don't want that no I mean really and
truly it was like well I mean just an
incredible honor and and again so
surreal to be a part of something like
that both Troy and I were saying this at
the time that it was like you know the
elation that you get over like landing a
gig like that is one thing but but
there's a lot to be said for then the
moment comes that you're like oh no that
way we don't because so much of what we
do is like you know like I said it is
kind of like birthing a vocal baby and
handing it over to somebody and kind of
going I've done the best I can do I rely
very heavily on my directors in terms of
like working collaboratively to get the
performance that they're asking for and
yet you're still kind of unaware of like
what's the final version of this gonna
look like and and there's a lot of
things that happen sometimes in
post-production where they will cut a
segment of a line out the audio could be
too low it could be too loud and be all
these different things we might have
gotten bad Intel in terms of what we
were supposed to achieve or record for
that particular scene which I've had
happen a lot of times in video games
where it's like you're flying blind so
often that we were just really just kind
of you're nervous about what may or may
not happen and yet at the same time
you're just so honored to have a chance
to be a part of something like that that
it was just like wow this is really cool
and I was glad that the game and the
performance was received well that
people understood you weren't
you act as if we were a replacement for
anybody and when people say like filling
those shoes I wish to say you can't buy
those shoes it's not that's not what
it's about it's about doing something
that would honor the idea that this is
an origin story and that the performance
would wind up being like Kevin and Mark
had established into the world
and thankfully people enjoyed that at
the gameplay I mean it's nice to see
people still kind of going back there's
going you know this is a good game this
is a really hard game a lot of good boss
yes pain it was a neat treat for sure
listen to have more like like all now
now there's stuff happening now they're
both what we're not hearing is yeah
you're doing good so far buddy
nice job oh look at you look what you
did you know that's that's how the game
is supposed to be played
wait I'm still time terrible I just I
put you on to save my own face that's
fine so then Justine and Lucas and I we
need to squat up and take these guys on
I'm ready to go but no I mean thinking
back on your careers what happened you
know the kind of breakout roles for you
that you've really enjoyed doing what
are the ones that people come up to you
at places like comic-con and talk to you
about well this is yes video game I've
ever been in with the biggest role of a
of a game I've been I've been in some
bigger games but I've always had other
characters or I've done like multiple
supporting characters so this is the
biggest movie for a video game which is
really exciting
um much newer i voiceover than right so
but I've done like before this I've done
a lot of promos and a lot of commercials
and
biggest my biggest animated show was
Golden Bear um as a little red
riding-hood which was so exciting which
is cool too because I'm anything you get
to be a part of like with four little
kids that's the stuff that to me there's
always like that just has the longest
those have legs
those those gigs last for a long time
and there's a new audience kind of
coming online all the time and so it's
it's a neat thing like when you get to
be a part of like a little little kids
series like that I mean along the same
lines I think a lot of a lot of people
their introduction very often when
they're younger is is to gaming and that
kind of thing would be something along
the lines of Sonic the Hedgehog so I get
a lot of the sonic fanbase that reaches
out and then like without a doubt but
between Ezio and Mirage I mean those
characters you know it's it's a neat
thing Sonic's a little bit of a
different fanbase because there's been
other actors who portrayed it so people
have their favorites but with something
like Ezio or Mirage it's always nice
when you don't have to worry about
somebody going well you're not my Mirage
you're am I at Theo and it's like I'm
the only one so it's a but it's such a
neat thing to be a part of anything like
that so you know I'm also much older so
yes that's not that module's ancient
when you're when you're taking on a role
is what's kind of like can you do
recognize in advance it's like oh people
are gonna love this character people
gonna latch on today I feel like I have
any idea because can go in so many
different directions um feel like
especially for apex legends they said
they were doing no publicity whatsoever
before it came out and so I was kind of
thinking that's you're staying in
strangers like okay well Polly it'll do
well but maybe it won't um and that's
okay I'm just really happy to have the
job and to be working happy to be acting
doing doing what I love to do for a
living and I don't really think that
much about it so when something does hit
like apex legends its surprise to me and
it's such a pleasant surprise yeah I had
the exact same experience I remember
being on a break with Chantel and Drew
and like the the crew from the mill like
we were all sitting around when we were
literally recording the mocap for the
the launch trailer and I remember Drew
at the time saying like you know yeah
this is coming out in I was saying like
so when you guys you know thinking about
doing this and I was thinking I was
gonna hear like a year out he says Oh
January and I was like in my mind I'm
going oh man okay this this was like
October or November no joke and I was
like I don't see how and then when he
said the same thing it was like yeah
we're gonna do it all where it literally
it's just gonna be maybe at midnight the
night before we'll launch something or
tease it but it's gonna come out agree
to play launch trailer boom the whole
things and I remember thinking wow
that's crazy in this day and age where
you know how do you find an audience
anywhere I just remember thinking that
that's an ambitious approach to this and
I had forgotten all about it and then on
February 2nd I think it was or fourth I
remember that was the day after the
Super Bowl that it I started get a text
message from one of my buddies because a
big gamer text it's nice like are you in
this new game and I was like I don't
know what you know what are you talking
yeah it pecks legends and it's funny
because we very often work on video
games under a code name so we don't even
know what we're working on sometimes you
don't even know what the final version
is gonna be called and so all the sudden
I was like oh yeah yeah I am in that is
that out and then and then I just
started watching I started following on
social media I started watching what had
happened that week and it can go that
way so many times I mean it's cansada to
think that there's been like animated
series that I've been a part of that
just kind of come out they don't catch
an audience and they go away and they're
phenomenally written shows that are
phenomenally well produced and it's like
it just kind of goes that way so you
never there's an old adage I think in
all of entertainment that that the only
thing anybody knows is that nobody knows
nothing and it's like you just never
know when something's gonna be a map I
mean who would have thought that like
something like Napoleon Dynamite would
have been yeah was you know when it
would have been just as direct
- video little thing it's I get just
blows up to become like a cult classic
and it's like that's that's this
industry so you never ever know it's
it's kind of a it's excitement and you
can't you don't you don't go in and
thinking I'm gonna be a part of the
biggest thing ever it's like now you're
not now you're not performing now you're
now you're thinking about the end result
as opposed to going I just what do I
want what do I want to do for my
director right now for the client are
you doing well performance capture these
days or used to kind of should strictly
sticking to voice for me personally
apex was my very first full performance
capture gig I'd done a bunch of like
facial motion captured with the helmet
prior to that but this was the first you
know putting on the ping-pong suit and
and and dancing her around and we'll I
mean we'll see it's like it you know it
seems like the technology is catching up
I have suffered in the past when the
technology couldn't catch up to take a
five foot five actor and stress them I
can remember I remember the first time
that I went in for a role and as I was
in the waiting room this is many years
ago I went into the waiting room and I
was showing up as a voice actor they
were looking for voice actors but it was
it was also gonna be a mocap thing and
on the sign-in sheet it said we're
looking for actors who were 511 and
taller and and I remember like calling
my agent and I was going and for the
first time in my life I'm too short for
a voice-over a role I think things are
changing so I I don't I don't tend to I
tend to be strictly voiced for the most
part of what I'm working on just seen
what about you
I only ever done facial capture so I've
never done performance capture but
that's something that is looked really
cool and I'd love to try it if I get the
opportunity
Prabhat in the chat says I just want to
thank Roger for being such a huge part
of my childhood with characters like
Ezio Chris sonic and Batman and that
kind of relates to a question to more
put in earlier which was who you're
acting heroes whether you know it's
voice over or just acting in general do
you see Justine how old I am with like
I've reached that
where are all of you in my bedroom right
now how do I turned on the Wi-Fi why are
you all laughing Justine you go that's
but honored to be a part of somebody's
childhood but holy cow does that make me
feel old
they might still be young they might
just be on the cusp of teen
it's all in there I can't fight it well
I started out doing musical theater ever
since I was old and went to college for
theater in New York my my biggest and
Chin's are the people like Bernadette
Peters Mandy Patinkin um the the theater
greats um actors gosh I mean three Laura
Linney
um this strong female actresses love
those Oh for voice actors um my cousin I
know this is really corny but my cousin
Teja Valenza who's a voice actress she's
amazing and we actually met each other
through voiceover we are cousins minded
we we didn't we didn't know each other
ten years ago we're cousins by marriage
and we we happen to be at the same
voiceover agency and met each other at a
party and I said I think we might be
related and she's amazing she's poison
ivy and some Star Wars stuff and she's
controlled promo voice-over actress so
she's a big inspiration to me and I just
look much
Oh charming it's it's as far as
voiceover heroes it's like I I I'm not
trying to sound like disingenuous when I
say like I'm in awe of like the people
that I get to meet and work with all the
time and it's like and I I what a really
cool thing that's happened in my life to
where I've gotten to like work with you
know my voice acting heroes it might
might aft Hartley job into the Union had
charlie adler as my director Tara Strong
and Maurice LaMarche all in one room and
I was good and kept make a mistake just
but it was like you know and I remember
Maurice and I've told him that so many
times and I still can't get over it like
my brother and I had a VHS tape of a
Rodney Dangerfield comedy special young
comedians special and Maurice was a
young comedian that was on there doing
impressions and it was like we burned a
hole in this VHS tape like we watched it
so many times and I was I remember like
telling Maurice my I know your act
I mean I've watched that you know you're
doing all your impressions yet neato
reasonably and I'm like I know your act
and that to then be you're in the room
with you when I just was barking up a
tree of voiceover as a potential career
and now here I am is like it's such a
surreal moment and then to have done so
many things with them throughout the
years has just been like it's incredible
and I and I I mean it when I when I say
I get to work with some of the most
creative fun zany crazy awesome
you know just incredible human beings so
I I don't know as far as like my heroes
I get to I get to say they're my
colleagues it's a neat thing I'm always
in awe of what people can do I just seen
questrom the chat not normal but magical
asks do you have a favorite Broadway
musical and if so which is your favorite
song from it my gosh of course um
Sunday in the park with George is my
favorite Broadway musical
and my favorite song is move on Stephen
Sondheim is my favorite musical theater
composer he's so curly I'm Roger a lot
of questions about your bird pictures do
I really I really enjoy you were so into
taking pictures of nature one question
from the chat for Michael nevus is can
you throw some bird lines into Mirage
wall
I think you could get in with respawn
and say we might have to yeah we might
have to we might have to work on
something like that I'm trying to think
what we could do it can do but yeah
that's neat yeah and the bird thing it
literally is like you want to talk about
one of the odd things I mean it's hard
to it's hard to think of like you know
positive aspects of the lockdowns and
the entire pandemic scenario but the
idea that it was like having to sit down
and get small and just kind of look
around I was suddenly finding myself
kind of looking out a window and just
spending more time I used I used to love
taking photographs of like the
hummingbirds but that was more like a
challenge and just trying to like
practice photography and work on
different techniques and things like
that but in just wanting to dive back
into that as a way of sort of passing
time I then started really kind of
becoming intrigued by all the different
birds that were visiting this little
fountain and and found myself kind of
going oh oh I'm becoming like a bit of a
birder and and and then I just thought
well what better thing to do right now
than when we're all sort of stuck and
it's like I'll just share you know since
I I try to be aware of the fact that
it's like people are gonna follow me not
because of that they're gonna follow me
because of maybe a character I've voiced
or something that I'm a part of that
they want to you know have a little
insight into but I also look at it like
but I rather than just self promote all
the time here's something I'm passionate
about something I'm learning and if you
like it
so be it if you don't that's fine movie
if you don't like the bird pictures but
it's been a thing to kind of share that
with folks and I'm glad that people are
I'm glad that people are enjoying it and
I've learned so much and have learned
so many different groups that exist it's
it's just a neat thing to be a part of
now so I'm like super excited to kind of
get back out and actually start maybe
meeting up with some birding groups and
and and nerding out nerding and birding
even harder once we can get back out
there that should be you should they
have a youtube channel netting and
birding converting to bird birding
hurting you think when it's safe to
travel then do you think that you will
go on birding exhibitions I know I know
people that like go all over the world
to see Birds
do you are you that yeah I could I could
see myself I could see myself trying to
combine so the nightscape photography
and the Astro photography is still like
a big passion for me but that all takes
place after dark and and very often I
enjoy hiking and mountain biking and
doing that kind of stuff so there's a
part of me that's like well if you're
looking to kind of like you know scratch
the photography hitch during the day
what better thing than to actually try
to combine and go alright well if I'm
gonna go pick a dark sky site you know
in another state somewhere then why not
also pull out the Audubon Society app or
merlin bird ID and start seeing like
well what what species would be
available out there and is there a is
there an uncommon one that i might want
to go find and you know be on the hunt
for that kind of thing so yeah i could
easily see myself going i need to go get
this you know i need to go get a photo
of this bird but yeah but it's it's been
a neat thing it has been a very it's
been a really neat thing to kind of like
give me perspective on on on a lot of
things in terms of just watching the way
that their little world exists and then
you start seeing the connectivity of
everything you start seeing what they're
doing how the other plants are
responding how the other animals are
responding it's been a really neat thing
to to kind of have the world get very
small like that
alright Chad Chad is just posting
hashtag noting and birding now so I
think you have to make it a thing
birding and hurting hurting in a birding
I love it
what I'm doing as well as taking as your
photography what are you doing during
lockdown playing games are you reading
or watching anything keep yourself
clearly not playing apex legends enough
Justine what are you doing Oh what am i
doing um I my million new recipes um a
lot of pie yeah my mom and I'm
coordinating with my mom so we've been
we've been cooking up a ton getting
farmers market boxes every week and
vegetables in whole new ways and I got
this really amazing new cookbook from
one of my favorite chefs in New Orleans
that was kind of a New Orleans take on
Mediterranean food so I've been making
delicious food from from his cookbook
been playing a lot of scattegories on
zoom and and with friends my boyfriend
and my mom and I will place categories
to the Macdonald you have to play
Michael McDonald as loud as you possibly
can distract but also I do a weekly with
some of my college friends that were we
were all in Peters school together and
we're all organ California Connecticut
New York planning just folding is over
and we can travel and again we're
planning get together and gonna rent a
big house in Oregon and just have a
crazy crazy weekend I'm very excited
about it
good plan yeah
carriage when says Roger if you made
videos of your birds would you do some
comic dubbing over them I've already
done that in fact I it might even be on
YouTube still yeah I just again I was
bored it was like it's funny I do these
little things and people go like yeah
give give us more I'm like it took me a
week and a half to do that I can't
I'm happy to do it and have it exist but
no of course I might get inspired one
other time like it's really funny these
little gold finches these little birds
they just go bonkers with bathing it's
very funny to watch how the different
birds respond to the ways in which they
kind of clean off and the little gold
finches they just get drenched and I
thought it was funny so I set up the
camera outside by the little fountain
that I did it in slow-mo and it just
became this little scene between one guy
that was just going bonkers and flipping
through the water and he was there for
who knows how long and another bird came
over as this bird was sitting there
bathing and the bird just kept looking
at this one bird like what is wrong with
you and Ann flew away and I thought well
there's a sea and so yes there is I have
a youtube account
I rarely post on I've been trying to
find a way to stream like images of the
moon connecting a DSLR camera to
telescope to livestream images of the
moon of that kind of thing but it's I'm
learning OBS and all these other live
streaming things and I'm you know
clearly as you can see how good I am at
at Apex legends the the whole streaming
broadcast platform is another there's
another language to itself for me so I
hopefully will do that someday but if
you go to Roger Craig Smith I think is
the YouTube channel you might see that
that little bird
on there so yes it exists if you need
tech help we've got Eric we've got the
voice of God who's been helping us get
set up for today okay you can further up
okay thank you
it's so freaky man are you in my room
I just seen people the child calling for
you to do cooking Street oh that would
be fine I've done some some some stories
may be really fun
maybe cooking in character some French
food that'd be really funny they're
gonna be great
that's a serious right that but you
can't cook with gas and I mean it's a
everything's got to be like an
electrical range or you just you just
take the plug and just jam it it into
like whatever you're cooking and just
electrocute it to fry it that's the only
thing you can do cannon uh puppet who
was the person who said that thank you
for being in there and that in during
the childhood Roger they said they're
only 21
didn't mean to make you feel old but
they asked oh but anyone is there any
one particular performance in a game
that stands out to you in recent years
hmm I think that's just general question
yeah I mean like obviously for both of
us just like um ones that we've played
or just like in general like all of
gaming I think I think just a general
performance they don't they don't say
your performance okay
just aim rabbi you any games they like
any any anything that caught your ear I
mean so many but um I worked on uh I
worked on Spyro um the new version and
Kenny is just so good
I just love Tom Kenny so much he's so
hilarious I've worked with him before
on a couple other projects and so in awe
of the characters he can do I mean
besides the fact that he's spongebob he
that's the biggest range it's insane so
I Johnny yes and a very sweet person oh
no guys where did you rank the seventh
that wasn't too bad I was gonna say it's
coming up to two o'clock so that might
have to be the last one that's funny
but but a great stream we got Roger his
first wins matter and for direct relief
the doubt the donation links are still
gonna be open we're running this thing
for like four more weeks five more weeks
donation links will be open that whole
time thank you to everyone who's donated
and spread you know retweeted the stream
and ask questions it's been really nice
to have a stream where we're just like
in the chat as much as we are and thank
you so much to roger and justine for
answering all those questions i'm
playing with us thank you guys you guys
so much
thank you guys thanks for a buddy who
donated and who watched me ruin your
impression of apex legends good that
window under damage and you got the kill
though you want the killer yeah i dealt
a hundred damage in one game and didn't
get a kill dealt five damage and got a
kill I will never understand this game
five damage is still damage like the
chat zone Jordan max thank you guys
thank you no super fun everyone I don't
forget to join us here tomorrow future
of gaming everyone PS 5 who knows what
we're gonna be seeing but we'll be
having a pre and post-show
we'll be dissecting all the big
announcements hopefully getting a first
look at some next-gen games and maybe
you two in some of them you just can't
tell us that would be the ultimate
betrayal but join us here tomorrow 12:30
Pacific time thank you for watching
see
[Music]
[Music]